I am gonna go out on a limb and say that
this is better to dunk Oreos in than
milk that orange juice is better than
milk I said it it's on the Internet I
just don't know why I like how it looks
it just looks appealing so you know it
doesn't really gross you out until you
say oh it's mayonnaise I think it's
gonna be really terrible and it's gonna
taste like crap I'm actually very
excited about this because I think it's
gonna taste really good
[Music]
that's okay the mouth field was weird
not gonna lie oh no I like it I'm fine
with it it makes it taste like cream
cheese oh my god I actually hate it this
is sick
it tastes worse than I thought it was
way better than I expected I like
mayonnaise in half gram conceptually I'm
not against this also I feel like apples
going salads like people put apples and
silage then you put pepper and salt on
it so I mean I'm not opposed to this one
oh I think I like this sure oh god I'm
really into this superior how believing
yes yeah this is really good this is so
much better than eating just the plain
apple mmm I don't like that this is
actually pretty decent this tastes like
a fancy appetizer if you're like it just
like covered my whole tongue with a lot
of flavor and like none of them were
complimentary to each other it enhances
the flavor a lot more totally oh my god
this is surprisingly really good all
right I would not have thought to put
salt and pepper on those license before
but the bekkie really good no no
absolutely not please take it away
[Music]
I'm excited cuz I love Oh J and I'm
always eating Oreos
no thank you as I know at first glance
I'm taken aback but thinking about it
like chocolate and orange is absolutely
a thing and then there's like cream in
the cookies and we got like a creamsicle
situation here I will do this in the
name of context oh yeah I like this it's
not that bad
it doesn't really coat the cookie that
much is it weird to say like I feel like
I like this more than milk
I was Nona was skeptical about this but
I read she kind of really liked it okay
this is really interesting because I
really like flamin hot cheetos hmm I
feel like at least this is gonna cool
down the heat of the hot flaming cheetos
but I think it's gonna be disgusting
part of what you make Shiro says is
they're crunchy I'm looking forward to
trying it I think it might be
surprisingly good but it just is just
scary
I'm literally teary great though I'm not
looking forward to eating this made it
cold I'm eating a cold cheeto put it in
your freezer
it literally numbed all the fire eNOS it
actually stays like cereal like spicy
cereal that's not bad you're eating
flamin hot cheetos you got to commit to
it you don't need to put training wheels
on them if you want to dump these in
milk get plana Cheetos million percent
well you know I feel like I'm still open
through trying anything at least once
I'd like to try more not against it I
think I need to open up my fridge a
little bit more I mean something sounds
really gross to me but at least I gave
it a chance fact this is happening on
camera kind of shocks me but like I've
never had nachos before
[Music]